hello the internet i'm gav thank you for
joining me
in this big empty void this video is
sponsored by google one
google one is a subscription from google
that gives you more cloud storage to use
across google drive google photos and
gmail
so in order for google one to help us
make this video i'm actually going to be
having someone else edit it and i'm
going to upload
all of the footage from right here in
the studio using a little 5g base
station
and that means while i'm sweeping up at
the end hopefully my editor is already
well on the way to downloading the
footage here's a little bit of me
uploading yesterday's time lapses
behind me on the floor you may have
noticed that someone has come out
and set about a thousand mouse traps
unfortunately that someone was me took
me about seven hours yesterday
had some close calls
what i'm going to do is put powder paint
on each mouse trap trying very carefully
not to set them off
different rows of colors so that when i
set one off we should
get a glorious chain reaction of mouse
traps hurtling up into the air
kicking paint all over the place for a
lovely slo-mo
shot unfortunately due to the fact we
don't really like to waste stuff
on this channel these mouse traps are
old they were used in the trampoline
video
because of that they've been sat in a
bucket for about three years
some of them seem to be one use
some sort of don't really function and
some have rusted
beyond all recognition so i'm just very
nervous to be honest i'm just going to
continue now
finish setting them up and just get to
it
i cannot describe how nerve-wracking
this is i feel like the further into
this that i get
the shakier and more mistakes i'm making
i've only got what like 12 more to place
here and then i'm gonna stop
but it is nerve-wracking so as i
mentioned in the intro some of them
the spring has snapped some of them
the arm is bent some of them the wood
shattered on the first use
one of them was burned i'm not sure how
that happened another trick i've learned
is to face away from the completed area
because sometimes when you're
bending it back to set it it will just
shoot out of your hands straight
forwards
it's not what you want i believe i have
now set more mouse traps than most
humans
um only those in pest control can give
me a run for my money i think
i also might be up there in um most
mouse traps purchased with absolutely no
intention of
trapping a mouse it's much harder than
doing it on the trampoline because on
the trampoline we didn't have to worry
about
proximity they didn't actually have to
be touching because we knew that the
bounce of the trampoline
would set them all off this one they'll
they'll only get set off if one lands on
them so
we're really just hoping for
that is the eighth time i've snapped my
finger all right let's do one more
then we're done okay that's all i'm
doing
let's call it a thousand it probably
isn't a thousand it might be way less
than that
i know i bought a thousand and most of
them have been used let's call it 900.
okay before i put all the color on i'm
just going to do a quick test to see
if it can indeed handle a little splodge
of color
okay seems to say we can be quite
violent with it
i won't be but it's good to know
[Music]
i am shaking like a leaf
interestingly i didn't have to buy
anything for this video
it's all stuff i already had left over
from various videos throughout the years
[Music]
so if it doesn't work we've only wasted
money on all the lights in the studio
now would be a very inconvenient time
for an earthquake
[Music]
but it is 20 20.
[Music]
oh
okay the bag ripped almost dropped a
full bag
on the side of the mouse traps there
also paying close attention to my lab
coat flaps
[Music]
[Music]
okay now i'm going to attempt here on
the smaller pieces just to push them up
into position
[Music]
ah
number nine
[Music]
i haven't actually thought about how i'm
going to trigger them yet
i think i'm just going to chuck a couple
of mouse traps on the back rows
i hope that that's enough
i feel like there'll be a lot of people
wanting just to skip to the slow-mo on
this one
those of you who stuck with me keeping
me company on this little journey
i appreciate you
oh here we go okay this is it
here i'm just going to grab a handful of
mouse straps and chuck them on the back
okay
here we go
i'm gonna run around there hit the
[Music]
button
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
yes
[Music]
absolutely terrifying i hope i didn't
run in front of one of the cameras
i don't know i don't know what i was
doing there
the aftermath seems like most of them
went off there's a little section here
that didn't
but most of them i think did i can't
believe it
oh i think i'm going to struggle to do
the outro without a stupid grin on my
face after that
i'm just so relieved it worked there's
so much time and effort riding on that
going right
like if it partially went off or i had
to sort of re oh i can't even imagine
i'm sorry i'm so relieved hopefully you
enjoyed that footage especially if
you're able to watch it
on a 4k tv or something like that i'm
very excited to get it back to a bigger
screen
and give it a look myself big thanks to
google
one for sponsoring this video every
google account comes with 15 gigabytes
of free storage but
sooner or later you will run out and
have to delete things so if you're
sharing files with family members
the best option is just to upgrade the
storage google one is a paid membership
rooted in cloud storage with plans
starting from 1.99
for 100 gigabytes going all the way up
to two terabytes
of online storage you can also use some
google one features for free
like the storage manager which helps you
easily find and delete large files
that's taking up your cloud storage
space
i love it not only because i frequently
have to upload giant 4k
raw phantom files but also because it's
so well integrated with gmail which i
use for keeping in touch with
family and friends and co-workers it's
very seamless
it's a service that i've used for many
years i rely on it in fact whenever
we're doing
large projects there's often various
versions of videos to go up and review
and
lots of phantom footage to upload and
the larger storage options
have really helped me out and prevented
me from having to meet up with people in
real life
delivering hard drives so that's a plus
for me if you think google want to be
useful to you make sure you download the
google one app
or go to one.google.com to explore the
various features and plans that you can
get there's a link in the description
below
thank you very much for sticking with me
through that video that was quite the
process but hopefully you like the
footage
make sure you subscribe and i'll see you
in the next video
time to get cleaning
oh dear where do you where do you even
start with something like this
oh i forgot about them
i think less went off than i thought
big thanks to google one for sponsoring
this video